وفي خبر منتظر مفرح تطبيق المراسله
الفوريه واتساب يختبر حاليا ميزه تعديل
الرسائل بعد ارسالها كانت موجوده اكيد
احنا منتظرينها مطوروا هذا التطبيق يجرون
المزيد من التعديلات استعدادا لاطلاق هذه
الميزه وقفي وقت قريب لكافه المستخدمين
وهذه ستتيح لمستخدمي واتساب امكانيه
التعديل على الرسائل بعد ارسالها لطرف
الاخر مجموعه الدردشه على ان يكون ذلك في
غضون 15 دقيقه او خمسه عشره دقيقه فقط بعد
ارسالها اي رساله يجرا تعديلها سوف تكون
هناك علامه يعني موسومه بكلمه معدله يعلم
كل من يقرا المحادثه وجميع الاطراف في
المحادثه ان الرساله قد عدلت متى بعد
الارسال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات